[Music]
so it's been long
known that uh people have taken offense
to
grocery store labels such as the ethnic
food section is this the trader joe's
[ __ ] trader
there is a new petition for trader joe's
to rebrand
most of its food labels that happen to
be ethnic wow i find it i liked it
i thought it was cute i laughed so hard
because i'm like i didn't know they had
a traitor jose
there's a traitor ming's right yeah oh
yeah it should have been trader joe's
yeah because it's trader joe trader jose
like what's the italian one there's like
a there's a traitor giant
or something like that yeah so this is
trader ming's this is for all the
chinese peeps out there
be offended be very very offended were
you offended so
offensive wait is that the is that the
store name or is that the game
that is pretty [ __ ] up i think so why
is it [ __ ] up just be trader joe's
you can enlighten me well for me i just
saw it as playful with
the with the you know the just the the
food and the
food aisle or whatever you know like i
didn't see it as like racist or whatever
you had noticed it before the this
announcement because i had never noticed
it before but then once they announced
it i was like
it's it's like it was endearing for me
i'm trying to be inclusive
but i understand like but it's outdated
because when i saw that
the root of it like where it started i
understand why people are i guess
everything
is up no so for me i would actually what
i liked about it when i first saw it is
that
when i'm shopping and i'm like oh cool
like this is
they're them trying to create this brand
and make it like
i want to connect with you guys so for
me it seemed like
um the neighbor that's going hey
i think they were trying to be very
inclusive and i think it was very
innocent of them right so there's trader
min
if they were like trader ching chong i'd
be like what the [ __ ] yeah
that's something i would have made but
you could get away with it
kind of that's true well just so there's
trader mings right
shout outs chinese people bart i see you
and then for
my lovely mexicans in the room there is
traitor jose's
which is fair still that i'm not
offended by it's so funny because i saw
that all over twitter and i didn't get
it i was like
are people mad uh yeah people are mad
but um
because i didn't say i didn't know there
was trader jose's or anything so i was
just reading taco shells like that's
racist
oh true yeah it's so small do you think
that's racist
taco shells no no dude the jose the
minks the meaning the host
no it's just it's just like why that's
the only thing
just why why are they changing it yeah
well just keep trader joe's like their
brand and then maybe like do other
things that are inclusive like you're
already doing hispanic products like
that's already dope
i would say if they start doing like
middle eastern or like uh oh dude
wait for it so then there is this trader
isis
joe i i see you too there is a trader
joe
son that's [ __ ] cool
i think that's so cool and then the team
i didn't forget you either
there is a arabian
for middle eastern food arabian you find
that offensive
no it should have been traitor nadeem i
i don't
i don't get mad about these things
that would have been that would make me
laugh because that's so dumb but then
stuff like that if i saw like a person
at the store being like
oh it's a arabic what is it arabian
arabian area is that why you think
people are offended because they're
taking it as like
that because they're trying to represent
something that's not genuine
from that region not that it's not
genuine i just feel like i could see
that perspective
oh because it's kind of like taco bell
yeah and then going jose's bell and it's
like what [ __ ]
it's not mexican that's the perspective
i get it now but if that's not the
perspective no
because i can clearly see that's what
people in the middle east would like to
eat like
there's tabouli there's falafel there's
but it's not like how their mom made it
though it's it's kind of whitewashed
well zenku's kitchen
isn't like how my mom made it well my
mom is we're not that people but
we should start a petitioner against
vancouver because like to me what's the
difference between
like this versus uh like a company
that's like
lgbtq friendly and then they have like a
rainbow flag it's like hey
guys just let you guys like though what
is it means my [ __ ] too
no that's ming dynasty i don't think
it's the same really well because the
lgbtq plus community that's their flag
yeah so they're representing imagination
secrets chicken which one's ryan
seacrest chicken yeah is he gay
is he gay i don't think he is right
who's that who's that actor from uh
helen kumar harold kumar oh neil patrick
harris yeah amanda that came out neil
patrick harris chicken yeah all white
people look the same
then i'm like what is he good at him
individual like endorsing that chicken
yeah i think it's different like trying
to appropriate
or like because a lot of people see this
as a appropriation culture but i think
a lot of the anger actually stems from
the history
as to why they even did this to begin
with so what's this
oh thank you does it taste good though
because if it tastes bomb it's good
i love trader joe's i love trader joe's
too i want to know why people are mad
though
me too i want to get mad people were
looking up the history of trader joe's
and they realized that the original guy
the guy that started his name is joe
something
yeah you would think it's joe right joe
joe
and guess what he was a wizard of the
kkk and he's like no wonder he's gonna
be mad
his name is joe coulombe coulombe quite
sure what what uh
what background that is joe columbe and
sounds italian trader joe's uh
and he was inspired by a book called
white shadows in the south seas
and basically what this book it was
about was about like white people going
around
colonizing and kind of like taking over
territories in like the south and east
uh asia oh so is it like a trade post
where
and the colonies they had trade okay the
trading companies back in like the early
1900s
and like 1800s and and basically if you
know anything about the trading
companies
yes there's a lot of trade and like
cultural like expansion and like you
know what not
but also you know left room for a lot of
you know
rape and pillaging and like just a lot
of the exploitation of cultures and
stuff like that
so there's it's controversial in that
aspect of it
and then um also he was
he was inspired by disney theme parks uh
jungle cruise ride what the [ __ ] what
part of it the well the jungle cruise
ride is basically
what it's a boat ride through what the
jungles and there's like aborigines and
like ethnic tribes and stuff like that
but they're all kind of posed and like
done up in a way that feels
savage savage-like yeah cause in trader
joe's there's like barrels and buckets
and cargo nets and stuff so like the way
they make things oh
yeah i was like oh [ __ ] that's where i
got it from oh yeah so here's a picture
of the jungle cruise
uh that i found and that's just like an
example of like the kind of caricatures
that are in in the ride and so and
there's always some parrot or like some
birds like
true yeah you know there's always a bird
making a monkey sound yeah
there's monkeys yeah because you know
the birds they copy them they do yeah
yeah how cute they do and then you hear
it you hear it and then you hear cricket
you know they're like putting in a
loudspeaker what are the noises do you
hear joe
you're so awesome dude you don't hear
that when you're on the boat and you're
just like wow it feels like i'm in south
america
we're all focusing on the caricature
stuff and you were just focused on the
magic
you know what my favorite part is though
when they shoot the fake gun
and you're like oh [ __ ] the arrow no no
the gun with the the alligator the
taurus person
oh it's coming something's charging at
the elephant
oh [ __ ] maybe i don't know maybe it's
indiana jones
no no yeah the point is it's racist
people
yeah it's it's it's deemed racist now
and
uh and then this is also brought a lot
of attention to disney
to want to revamp jungle cruise now yeah
the way they should do it
is those guys right there should be
holding iphones
oh they should be there holding iphones
and then like
you go and then when you go there's no
animals
and there's no trees it's really hot
because we cut down all the rainforest
really hot yeah all the animals are gone
because we poached them all
yeah yes that should be the modern day
modern day
yeah like the waters like this much
because it's called
it's all polluted it's all polluted yeah
when you go by there's like
cans and plastic face masks everywhere
yeah there's a great message there you
know be safe with kovid and then there's
you know
climate change all that kind of stuff is
all invested in that little
image right there that would be a good
disney ride to like create the
apocalyptic future of where we're
heading
it's a bad world
so that kids could be inspired to not
make it a reality
i know did y'all see the disney walk
disney
the the disney comeback uh oh that was
so funny the way they edited it
with like scary move like scary music
and yeah
i feel all like doomed yeah i didn't
pull the video but basically
disney was trying to open but they did
open up in uh in orlando
oh right right up and they had a
commercial come out and
basically all the workers are in uh
masks and they're all like welcome back
home welcome welcome home welcome and
that was called welcome home the
commercial and so then
like disney world all the people's homes
and people were like
no it's stay home they actually
re-edited it yeah so a lot of people
took that same clip
and since everyone's wearing masks you
can't really see their mouths moving so
a lot of people
re-edited the video put their own music
in scary music
for one another one was just putting
like something similar music-wise and
they've just
said stay home stay home stay home and
so like everyone's just kind of like
making fun of the fact that disney opens
you know that
you know that new song the the
they covered the i got five on it yeah
from uh
get out no not us exactly from us so
then they put that song over that video
too
it's like damn like how do they not see
that it's just so dangerous there's a
lot of disney world world
employees saying too like i don't feel
[ __ ] safe
but i have to work i need to get a
paycheck so it's like oh no it doesn't
i'll go is it cheap right now i'll go
disney world
is it cheap right now i mean if you want
to go here oh you have to fly to florida
to get in i'll go i'll go i'll go yeah
i'll go for you guys work or to just
have fun
both if they need help i'll go
i never been before i've never been
either yeah i want to know that
i want to see the tunnels because i have
friends that work at disney and they're
like yeah there's
underground tunnels yep the employees
only tunnels those ones
and i heard that the lunchroom is
[ __ ] dope it's pretty sick
employee yep does it have trailer wings
she was a part of the um the uh the
mulan show
like the parade the parade yeah they'll
be dancing and [ __ ] or was it aladdin i
don't know she
she wore some kind of costume and that
reminds me like if people can do this to
trader joe's and like
say that's appropriation couldn't they
do that to the disney princesses too
and there's like a aspect of
appropriation with that because it's all
ethnicities of prince
princesses now that's the part that i
think is scary because i think there's
appropriation to everything right like
even with this is this a white on white
fight
or are asians actually mad or like even
with this picture right here
are like i don't know quote unquote
jungle people are they mad
or is it like a white on white fight or
even traitor means is that asians mad or
is that a white on white there might be
some asians
yeah yeah i think it's everyone it's
like woke
uh woke on woke they're trying to like
go through everything and like cancel
everything
i don't know like i see i see the
intention i see what they're trying to
do
it's like yes we should stop
perpetuating racist uh stereotypes
racist
things about it and like we shouldn't
celebrate
racist past like i get it but then i
feel like there's like a fine line
and then like that line is just like so
blurry and then people are going to the
extremes and now
every single thing is canceled like you
can't you can't have an opinion on
anything
like everything has a horrid past
and it's just like oh my god it's
exhausting i'm tired
like i don't know i don't know how to
like actually
um i don't know how to be fully on
either side because to me they both seem
so extreme because even like let's say
like honda accord right is that
appropriating now like
to market to america they use an
american name for a japanese car
the accord yeah right isn't that the
same thing as trader means
well and what for me like i kind of like
so for me
i don't like when people get angry
because they're just angry right and
they want to follow the mob
and then that's what we're calling
cancel culture i do like however
when people are being called out like
something like this that is
misinformation that happens to be a
caricature that isn't accurate
to the uh an accurate depiction of a
certain type of of group
and adding to it they were on the jungle
cruise specifically yeah specifically
the jungle cruise
um so if if people were like hey you
know what keep that
but just make it accurate i'm like
that's tight because now at least tycho
when he sees it or like other kids or
other people they're gonna
see the correct stuff being displayed is
this not accurate i have no idea i have
no idea either
uh and what's up i guess i'm just
talking you know like is it like is it
having a 20 20 slice of life
accurate with trash is that accurate for
example with disney way i like that they
did with um
what was the ah the mexican movie
yes with coco is they had a bunch of
consultants of
that culture of mexican culture so they
moana too so they consulted with a lot
of
people within that community so that
they couldn't get it
so that's without consultation i'm
assuming i see you know what that's
gonna
evolve to eventually 20 years 30 years
down the line is going to be like
well those people you consulted with
don't speak for the entire culture
and we had to cancel it too and i'm like
what the [ __ ]
there's no right you can't do no right i
think there's always just going to be a
group that's angry no matter what you do
especially right now when everyone's
stuck at home we're in the middle of a
pandemic they don't know
they don't know how to like release
their frustrations any other way so it's
like oh let's pick apart every little
thing
and i yeah it's just it's a lot i don't
know
but yeah so uh jungle cruise movie
hopefully will come out soon because i'm
really excited for that the rocks in it
emily blunts in it and hopefully
with that movie coming out i'm not
sponsored by them or anything but with
that movie coming out
i'm thinking they might change the ride
oh like update it cause like like how
they did pirates of the caribbean
pirates of the caribbean was some
whack-ass jack sparrow should have kept
it old-school same
dude i like that one i like johnny depp
probably came out and
stopped appropriating us yeah and then
and then johnny depp
just was like i want it in my likeness
and they redid the whole i like the
the 3d thing that pops out at the end
with jack sparrow
i'm gonna go back and see the whole ride
for myself but they robbed my child come
with this man come with us
because disneyland used to be the the
[ __ ] it's still the [ __ ]
really yeah really hello guys thank you
guys so much for watching all of our
videos and i know it's been a million
years in the making but we finally got
just kidding news merch yup so make sure
you go down to the store below
and you can run around yeah you can get
a piece
of jk news and thank you guys for
supporting thank you
[Music]
bye-bye
[Music]
[Music]
you